first a personal question I was watching
a whole bunch of cords interviews and he
kept talking about how the first time he
read eraser it felt like the book was
for him like it was talking to him and I
feel like American fiction is going to
have that effect on a lot of people out
there so is there another movie you've
seen that felt like it was talking to
you like a character was looking at you
wow that's a really good question
there's so many things that I think I
love Cinema um and I feel like I'm I
think I've always been asked to see
myself in other people's stories so like
I can say something like William
Wallace when William Wallace is on the
rack and he has this Cry For Freedom or
whatnot I don't know what it is it's
probably every like 17 18 year old boy
at that time just felt like oh this
feels like me even though I'm not
Scottish I'm not fighting for
Independence but I think knowing and the
desire to want autonomy U like sounds so
silly but like I really relate to that
but then I I can relate to
anything keep keep going with your next
question because something else may come
back to me that is even more all the
examples you want to give so my next
question is working with cord of course
it's his first feature I have a feeling
there's going to be many more on the
horizon so what is something about his
approach to the work as an actor's
director that you're really excited for
actors out there to get to experience in
the future uh he's an egoless human
being he is incredibly confident and
competent in what it is that he knows
and he is willing to delegate those
things that he doesn't to people who are
as smart or smarter than him in other
Arenas of life and I feel like that sort
of makes for a wonderful com combination
of I'm I'm going to exude that that I
know and I'm going to be comfortable
with that that I don't and so if you
guys can help me fill in the gaps then
we get a chance to collaborate and
that's what a collaboration is and
that's how he trusted his actors from
casting them and then to seeing them
execute on stage or on set and the very
few notes every once in a while
suggestions Etc but he gave us the space
to play and it was fun it was every
second on that set was fun many
follow-up questions to that first so I
don't forget it does he have a monitor
dance is there anything he does behind
the monitor that signals to you he is
really digging a take yeah He he'll
he'll sort of like go back and forth
like you'll see like a little like sort
of just side movement type of thing and
he smiles he has a big beautiful
effortless smile and so when you see
that you're like all right we're in the
pocket oh I love that all right given
how you were just talking about your
collaboration with him going into
filming like when you first took the
role what part of Cliff or his
experience were you most looking forward
to playing but then I also want to know
a quality of his that you found along
the way that became more creatively
fulfilling to explore than you ever
could have imagined I think Cliff's the
youngest brother and so there's a
certain level of petulance to Cliff that
comes to me naturally as the youngest
brother in my sibling Trio um in birth
order and then I have a little brother
and little sister who are adopted that
came around 20 some odd years after me
um and then in terms of like adding to
my own personal repertoire I I feel like
there's a level of
poo with cliff and that you cannot be
your happiest self unless you are your
most authentic self and I think that
this sort of just cemented the lesson
that I've already known that like you
can't live your life for other people's
benefit If you're sort of dying on the
inside yeah I I'll go I'll go there
there next with a a very big scene for
you in the film that just broke my heart
into a million pieces can you tell me
about t tackling the the dance and also
the the conversation or the line
delivery with his mother when she says I
always knew you weren't a queer cuz it's
like beautifully scripted of course but
a moment like that has to be Pitch
Perfect and there's just like this this
incredible like weight and sadness that
takes over the character immediately
after she says that and it just like it
rocked me thank you
yeah listen it it's in in my family it's
interesting because I'm from St Louis
Missouri and there is a sort of tcid
level of acceptance of alternative
Lifestyles as long as people don't throw
things in your face right so I think the
way in which he was dealt with by his
mother and father they may have had a
knowledge of his Gus but as long as he
was not too ostentatious with it then
they could sort of have plausible
deniability right and so him dancing
with his mother trying to give her a
little bit of joy and these new
circumstances that she finds herself in
because she has been autonomous and
living in a home by herself Etc and now
is having to have be in an assisted
living facility like maybe I can help to
bring her a little Joy she likes the
music she knows that she likes to dance
and then it becomes interrupted by this
idea that that he can't still be who he
is with her and be
accepted which is heartbreaking for me
too
um and playing it with Leslie AUM who is
just a treasure and just sort of just
nailed it because there's two things
happening in terms of her dementia
because you're like how cognizant is or
isn't she and does it even matter at the
end of the day honestly that question
has been swirling in my head every every
single time I watch it over and over and
I can't I can't shake it and that's I
mean that's the the quiet power of a
moment like that like that in the movie
overall a like a little bit of a switch
here so and I'll I'll just warn people
that this happens towards the end of the
movie so it may be a spoiler go see
American fiction and then push play on
the rest of this but I wanted to turn
one other idea that happens at the end
of the movie towards you and your career
because when Lorraine tells Cliff you
can't impose your family and you just
see like your demeanor completely change
it is another really exceptional
performance beat right there so I want
to know what is that version for you in
your career the time when maybe you were
nervous to step on set join an ensemble
but there was such like warmth and
support there that you found you were
able to deliver your best work because
those people were there for you great
question P that's oh I I kind of clap
for that one I'll take it uh people
versus OJ um I was very much feeling
like one of these actors is not like the
other because I know who all of them are
and none of them know who I am and so my
first uh seen on set was with Courtney B
Vance and a friend of mine told me early
in my career said that you cannot be a
fan and in the game at the same time so
you look at all these wonderful people
around you whether it's Courtney or John
travolto or Sarah Paulson or Nathan Lane
or David swimmer or whomever and you say
like I'm a big fan and then you say
let's play ball right and Courtney being
the first scene between Cochran and
Darden was so gracious and so warm
and I felt like okay and I and I I said
like oh I can do this dance with people
whose dance steps I really appreciate I
was like I'm I'm okay I can do this and
that was a great moment beautiful answer
than beautiful movie I'm not going to
stop watching this movie I can't stop
watching this movie I'm mad because I'm
not watching new movies cuz I keep
watching this movie over and
over